Karl Rove Big Time George W bush  strategist now says that presidential  candidates are too old and they need  younger people this is being interpreted  as a signal that the Republican Party  should go more in the direction of Ron  DeSantis maybe than Trump or others now  Rove is not a trump guy and of course  the Maga people are saying Rove just  hates Trump that's it but it is true  that both sides even the Republican  electorate that tends to go for older  candidates seem to be looking for  someone younger whether this will be an  overt factor or not in 2024 remains to  be seen but do you agree is it time for  younger candidates let me know in the  comments